هناك العديد من الطرق للموت في إيطاليا ،
ولكن فقط أكثر الطرق بدائية
للبقاء على قيد الحياة كما كان فيشر
يستعد لهجوم النظام Enid
lib قد يكون هذا المأوى المؤقت هو
الفرق بين الحياة أو الموت لعائلته
ناتاليا حول موني عارضة أزياء أو
المدير في الضوء يجب أن يتحمل
ماهالو لا يعرف آنا لوسيا بيدروكا ،
لا أحد أعرف أنها لم تعرض
جنوة مارو من الآن السوق هامل
يفعل الكثير لتنظيف هجوم النظام
لاستعادة آخر
معقل كبير للمتمردين لم  لم يبدأ رسميًا بعد ،
لكن القنابل كانت تمطر بالفعل
على جنوب أدلب إيشود ، ويأمل أن يحمي الكهف
عائلته من أسوأ
الأسلحة التقليدية ، لكن في سوريا ،
حتى تنفس الهواء النقي هو أمر
غير مؤكد لا أعرف أحداً وقد
يكون كذلك.  لا ليس مضحكا أعني ألا
تعرف أن هناك من يحب الأسد وأكثر
مني
في الطابق العلوي في غرفة المعيشة الخاصة بهم يستعدون
للأسوأ هو كل ما يمكنهم فعله
للسكان هنا يخشون من احتمال حدوث ذلك.
هناك هجوم كيميائي بعد
التعليمات التي وجدها على الإنترنت
يستخدمها شهد حيث يمكنه العثور على أكواب ورقية ملونة
ضمادات من القطن والفحم
والأكياس البلاستيكية لإنشاء
مجموعة نجاة عائلته هذه الأقنعة الواقية من الغازات
المرتجلة بينما يمشي
شهد أطفاله في الظلام لتفقد
مخبأهم تحت الأرض دون أي مكان
تركوا للركض عندما تبدأ المعركة ، قد
يكون هذا ملاذهم الوحيد جيمانا كراتشي
سي إن إن اسطنبول